[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 tout de suite les titres de ce
mercredi 11 mars
et j - 4 avant le premier tour des
élections municipales actualité de la
campagne avec ce soir la présentation
des candidats à montigny le bretonneux
et magny les hameaux reportage avec
valérie bain à villepreux et puis invité
joséphine coleman ce berger maire
sortante de plaisir en lice pour un
nouveau mandat c'est du 14 au 21 mars au
théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et d'autres
lieux de l'agglomération les rencontres
in cité est clair chaque année une
thématique par le biais de conférences
spectacles et projections cinéma pour
cette quatrième édition est la ville de
demain essayez défis et le sujet choisi
et puis les adeptes de musique métal
avaient rendez-vous le week-end dernier
à guyancourt et voisins le bretonneux
métal ce faire se dérouler à la batterie
et la salle de la tour
retour sur la soirée de concerts du
samedi et on débute tout de suite ce
journal par l'information du jour
[Musique]
c'était une première aujourd'hui en
france en ce 11 mars une journée
nationale d'hommage aux victimes du
terrorisme même date que la journée
européenne choisit en commémoration des
attentats de madrid le 11 mars 2004
comme partout en france une cérémonie
s'est déroulée à la mi journée dans la
cour de la préfecture des yvelines à
versailles rendez-vous présidée par le
sous préfet thierry roland de thierry
laurent d'autres hommages également dans
les yvelines vous l'avez vu sur cette
dernière photographie à à poissy dans le
jardin de la paix l actualité du jour
liés forcément aussi aux coronavirus
depuis le premier cas a révélé il ya
tout juste une semaine dans les yvelines
le nombre de contaminés elle ne fait
qu'augmenter au dernier point publié par
l ars hier soir à 22h 65 cas étaient
recensés dans le département
un chiffre qui évolue constamment dans
ces cas a détecté à noter ceux de deux
sapeurs-pompiers de vélizy villacoublay
rappelons que dans les yvelines deux
personnes sont décédées une école celle
des sablons à poissy est fermé et puis à
8 classes 2
lully vauban le sont également deux
sites de diagnostic sont chargés de
réaliser les tests dans le département
les centres hospitaliers de versailles
et celui de poissy j - 4 avant le
premier tour des élections municipales
avec forcément l'épidémie de kovy 19
dans toutes les têtes le scrutin est
bien maintenue pour l'heure et les
procédures de procurations été facilitée
pour les individus confiner les
personnes vulnérables
une circulaire du ministère de
l'intérieur a été envoyée au préfet est
les habitants contaminés ou en
quarantaine peuvent demander à un loupé
j officier de police judiciaire de se
déplacer à leur domicile pour recueillir
la demande de procuration
en ce qui concerne les résidents des
ehpad les directeurs d'établissement
pourront remplir la fonction de l'opg j
et collecter les demandes direction
montigny le bretonneux ou trois listes
s'opposent pour ces élections elles sont
menées par laura mais requiert vivien
gasc et pierre déjean présentation de
ses candidats avec marylène yapi chine
la ville de montigny le bretonneux et
ses plus de 33000 habitants dont 23 1326
inscrits sur les listes électorales voit
s'affronter trois candidats ancien
directeur de cabinet de nicolas bour
michel laugier puis jean-luc ourgaud
laurent merckaert a quitté son poste le
31 décembre dernier pour se lancer comme
tête de liste de la majorité sortante
installé dans la ville depuis 2001 il
n'est membre d'aucun parti politique
mais de sensibilité centriste
nous avons l'intention bien sûr de
préserver ce à quoi les gens sont très
attachés dans la ville c'est à dire un
cadre de vie privilégié des services
extrêmement important et aussi dans la
relation qu'il peut y avoir entre les
habitants et leurs élus une connexion
permanente
déjà candidat en 2014 où il avait réussi
à mener une liste divers gauche mêlant
parti socialiste écologistes et extrême
gauche et finalement investi par le ps
qui lui a permis d'obtenir un siège
comme conseiller municipal d'opposition
vision gasc se relance dans la course
aux municipales il a quitté le parti
socialiste avec qui il a milité durant
15 ans et mène une liste écologiste avec
sa binôme karolinska où on se présente
un binôme tête de liste et ça c'est
important
et dans tout à notre action municipale
l'idée c'est de construire des binômes
avec des gens qui travaillent ensemble
et pas des décisions ultracentralisée
entre les mains
d'une personne en c1 élus dans l'essonne
il a suivi la liste d'union de la gauche
de sandrine grand gang en 2008 et entre
au conseil municipal de l'opposition en
2010 en 2014 il ne parvient pas à monter
sa propre liste mais c'est chose faite
pour 2020 et cette liste fermement ancré
à gauche rassemble plusieurs mouvance de
la gauche lui même et membre du parti de
gauche
nous avons choisi une autre approche qui
donc que celle de ses trois grands axes
la démocratie la solidarité l'écologie
c'est une façon de présenter qui je
pense nous caractérise
à trak ils sont cinq à se faire face
pour ce scrutin dont le conseiller
d'opposition othman nassr où il s'agit
de sa deuxième candidature dans la ville
pour les municipales après celle de 2014
le conseiller régional s'est allié cette
fois ci à mustapha larbaoui ancien
président du club de football local pour
sa fin de campagne l'élu a prévu de
donner une réunion ce jeudi à la salle
jean baptiste clément et de réaliser
quelques opérations de porte à porte ses
priorités sécurité avec l'augmentation
des effectifs de la police municipale
éducation revenir par exemple sur la
suppression de leur d'études gratuites
ou encore baisse de la fiscalité les
propos les propos sont relayés par yves
christen vergès cela fait maintenant
plusieurs mois
on va à la rencontre des trappistes pour
leur présenter notre projet sur lequel
ça fait six années qu'on travaille qui
est cohérent avec tout ce qu'on a voté
pendant six années au conseil municipal
c'est un projet qui est complet qui
crédible qui concrets qui finançait et
donc on a envie évidemment que jusqu'à
la dernière minute
tous les trappistes puissent se rendre
compte qu'ils peuvent avoir une
meilleure gestion municipale que celle
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui cinq candidats
également pour ces élections municipales
à plaisir bonsoir joséphine coleman
berges dans sa maire sortant de la ville
vous êtes la tête de liste de plaisir
avant cette campagne du premier tour qui
arrive donc à sauter magie - 4 avant le
scrutin et quel bilan vous faites de
cette campagne menée à plaisir je fais
un bilan d'étonnement par rapport à la
teneur de cette campagne
j'ai toujours évoqué le fait que je suis
dans un respect total de la démocratie
et surtout des listes qui se présentent
face à nous avec des valeurs je dirais
pérenne que l'on voit au fur et à mesure
des années cette année c'est une qualité
une campagne très violente très
difficile et surtout je trouve acx
sur ma personne et des attaques très
violentes sur ma propre personne
je trouve ça un petit peu dommage parce
que je pense que la période d'une
campagne était une période où on doit
bien évidemment plutôt dire ce que l'on
veut faire et les projets que l'on ne
m'ont pas été assez mis en avant
je ne les ai pas vus en tout cas ce que
j'ai vu j'avais l'impression de les
connaître déjà puisque ce sont des
choses que nous défendons depuis de
nombreuses années
ce sont des sujets que nous avons
évoquées lors de nos différents réunion
et conseils municipaux puisque je veux
dire aujourd'hui
ne serait-ce que le programme que nous
nous présentons c'est un programme sur
lequel on travaille depuis longtemps
dans le cadre de séminaires ou dans le
cadre de travail avec mon équipe
est ce que pouvait l'être et terminer
cette campagne est ce qu'elle va se
poursuivre jusqu'au dernier moment que
vous autorise justement la loi
côté nous on a énormément travaillé on a
été sur sur le terrain on a été au
devant des habitants est énormément de
réunions chez l'habitant puisque si avec
quelque chose que je mets en place
depuis très très longtemps
moi j'aurais tendance à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a plutôt un sentiment
de sérénité que je voudrais remettre
parce que nous on a essayé de faire une
campagne positive vraiment dans la
dynamique et dans l'énergie que nous
avons toujours eu bien sûr
la campagne se termine vendredi soir
donc on est sur le terrain on est
toujours là on est toujours présent mais
bon je veux dire aujourd'hui je pense
que les électeurs ont déjà fait leur
choix et pourquoi vous être de nouveau
justement engagés dans cette démarche
ont presque vous si vous êtes réélu ce
serait votre deuxième mandat complet à
plaisir vous avez été une première fin
2012 mais là ce sera le deuxième mandat
complet vous savez un mandat c'est le
moment où on installe les choses c'est
un certain moment où on se rend compte
effectivement des grandes possibilités
que l'on a sur une commis comme une
aussi forte que celle de plaisir donc on
a enclenché toute une série de grands
projets structurants comme par exemple
le centre bourg qui n'est pas anodin
également l'éco quartier du val hibou
également la zone high-tech au niveau de
50 1 et 2 et de la zone de 5 à pauline
ce sont des projets tellement
structurants que il faut du temps pour
les enclenché et puis il faut les
accompagner donc celle dynamique que
nous avons mis en place des
à donner une image complètement
différente à plaisir vous le voyez bien
l'installation l'ère des 30 qui bien sûr
peut être critiqué en tout cas apporté
une vraie nature différente à plaisir on
a apporté aussi je pense une forme je
dirais de de douceur à notre ville aussi
et de dynamique c'est ce qu'on nous dit
et puis comme je demande aux gens qu est
ce qui vous manque à plaisir
véritablement bien sûr qu'il manque les
médecins mais est ce que vraiment je
dirais la ville est dans cette dynamique
de pouvoir trouver des médecins du chou
blanc demain aujourd'hui on en a trouvé
aujourd'hui j'annonce d'ailleurs que
nous avons depuis de nombreuses années
mis en place des activités très forte et
des relations importantes avec les
hôpitaux et avec des médecins et
aujourd'hui on peut annoncer que la
ruche et là que nous avons déjà quatre
médecins présents de généralistes qui
l'on arrivait un gynécologue qui va
arriver et d'autres groupes de médecins
qui sont déjà dans le travail avec moi
ou au niveau de l'hôpital et du
directeur de l'hôpital
voilà pour cette thématique un qui est
l'un des enjeux de campagne forcément
plaisir un autre enjeu c'est l'écologie
dont on parle dans toutes les villes
vous intégrez vous aussi dans plusieurs
axes de votre campagne notamment la
ville responsable vous souhaitez que la
ville ait vers le zéro carbone qu'on
sait que c'est possible
aller vers le zéro carbone en tout cas
faut en avoir l'ambition possible ce
serait ambitieux dans le sens un peu
impertinent même de ma part on n'est pas
les seuls
je savais bien que le carbone s'arrête
pas aux frontières de plaisir donc on a
mis en place toute une série d'actions
vous voyez bien dans la ville nature
dans notre programme et dans la ville
responsable on a toute une série
d'actions nous avons déjà fait des
actions n'est pas je dirais aujourd'hui
dans une annonce tout à coup comme ça
qui sort du chapeau parce que c'est la
mode
nous ne serait-ce que le résop que nous
avons mis en place la chaleur propre qui
est aujourd'hui qui vient de l'usiné
d'incinération
nous l'avons rajouter sur 6 km et
aujourd'hui c'est effectivement quelque
chose qui est très important sur notre
territoire
il n'y a pas que ça ça fait des années
que l'on met en place toute une série
d'actions et puis comme on parle aussi
de cette circulation 12 qui est
fondamental notre étude est terminée
l'étude est terminée nous a permis de
voir que l'on peut faire sur plaisir
plus de 24 kilos mais il faudra du temps
vous savez quand on promet quelque chose
il faut être capable de se dire qu'on a
les moyens
l'effet est aujourd'hui les
collectivités ont des moyens qui sont
les leurs et elles sont aussi limiter
les baisses de dotations sont archi
présent il faut être conscient de ça il
faut être responsable
il faut connaître les dossiers ce qui
n'est pas le cas de toutes les personnes
qui se présentent aujourd'hui parce que
quand il ya des personnes qui se
présentent et qui n'ont jamais été là
qui n'ont jamais été sur le terrain qui
aujourd'hui peuvent critiquer des choses
dans lesquelles il était je dirais même
partenaire mais qui effectivement
aujourd'hui critique parce que
effectivement l'idée est venue de nous
c'est assez inquiétant de voir je dirais
que la politique est prise comme un jeu
la politique n'est pas un jeu
la politique il faut avoir de
l'expérience de l'an viii mai de l'an
viii sincère et puis aussi de
l'abnégation parce que c'est de plus en
plus difficile la population a besoin
qu'on les accompagne
on est dans une période assez anxiogène
vous le savez et si vous le permettez je
les camps bien fallu que quelque chose
ce qui me semble assez fou c'est que
l'on nous fasse un procès d'intention
sur le travail qu'on n'aurait pas fait
au niveau de cette problématique du
courant la ville vous parlais justement
du coronavirus on sait que la
participation à plaisir pour les
dernières élections de 2014 vous avez
été élu dès le premier tour a été d'un
peu plus de la moitié des des plaisirs
roi est ce qu'il ya une crainte sur le
fait que coronavirus influe sur la
participation qu'il y ait moins de
plaisir war en l'occurrence qui se
déplace aux urnes c'est ce qu'on entend
mais a contrario je dirais plutôt de
mettre la peur auprès des plaisirs ouah
je voudrais leur dire que toutes les
précautions étaient prises depuis bien
longtemps des élections ça se prépare
des mois al avance aussi depuis
longtemps qui va y avoir les élections
donc dans la mesure bien sûr de nos
responsabilités avec les indications
préfectoral et de l'état nous avons
depuis longtemps prévu et mis en place
toute une série d'actions et on espère
bien que les plaisirs aux avants nous
faire confiance pour venir voter c'est
important de venir peut-être justement
sur ce premier tour puisque on a la
sensation que les choses vont aller en
s'empirant mais en tout cas au niveau de
plaisir je peux vous dire qu'on a un
contrôle permanent au niveau de tous les
équipements des écoles et surtout des
bureaux de vote où on a
mis en place beaucoup de choses qui vont
permettre de rassurer les gens donc
venez voter votre caisse que ce qui vous
semble le mieux mais venez voter c'est
important
merci joséphine coleman auberge le maire
sortante de plaisir tête de liste de
plaisir avancé face à vous patrick
jeantet rani injouable priou a admis
djamel niati également jean-louis m et
lève à coignières ils sont deux à
vouloir être à la tête du conseil
municipal les xavier girard et la tête
de liste de coignières à venir une liste
déjà engagés lors des municipales
partielles dans la commune de novembre
et décembre 2018 est menée à l'époque
par l'ancien maire adjoint ali
bousselham et quatre piliers pour son
programme l'environnement économie et
emploi sécurité et famille le candidat
souhaite d'ailleurs notamment aménager
le parc de l'après vendre y écouter ses
explications au micro de mickaël
landreau
nous espérons faire un lieu de loisirs
pour la famille avec une maison
intergénérationnelle à nouveau skatepark
et puis ensuite un boulodrome et surtout
une heure pour les enfants rénover ces
faits pour créer du lien n'y a aucun
endroit sûr coignières on peut avoir
toutes les populations de tous les âges
ça permettrait d'avoir un bâtiment avec
les nouvelles normes avec l'architecte
qui pourrait nous faire en sorte d'avoir
aussi bien la petite enfance que les
adultes que la gérontologie est la
campagne se poursuit également à
villepreux le week-end dernier la
candidate valérie ben proposé un atelier
et sécurité vélo sur la place du marché
est l'occasion d'exposer aux habitants
les points forts de son programme au
rayon et marie l'ania clichy atelier
vérif vélo ce samedi matin place du
marché
la liste agir avec vous pour villepreux
conduite par valérie ben proposé aux
habitants de faire vérifier l'état des
routes ou des freins de leurs deux roues
nous ce qu'on voulait démontrer c'est
que avec peu de matériel
avec peu de moyens on peut arriver à
sensibiliser les gens nous agissons
la liste se veut citoyenne ouverte
plurielle et participative
on est tous salariés on est engagé
effectivement chacun d'un point de vue
associatif et à notre niveau et
il ya un engagement sincère et réel
l'occasion pour l'équipe d'évoquer avec
les habitants les points forts de leur
programme la démocratie participative le
développement de la culture ou encore le
gel du projet central park
la liste s'oppose à la multiplication
des programmes immobiliers à ville
proche nous allons passer de 10000 à
treize mille habitants et nous trouvons
que c'est largement assez à l'échelle de
notre ville maintenant il s'agit
d'intégrer toutes ces populations de
retrouver en fête donc cette création
quartier a mobilisé beaucoup de
ressources financières
mais maintenant il s'agit de se recréer
en fait quand entre guillemets un bas de
laine pour pouvoir améliorer la qualité
de vie de tous les villes provient dans
tous les quartiers d'une pseudo
concertation mais en nous imposant un
nombre de logements et nous c'est pas
comme ça du tout qu'on veut fonctionner
nous c'est vraiment dans le participatif
avant le premier tour valérie ben donne
rendez-vous une dernière fois aux
habitants le vendredi 13 mars à 20h30 à
l'école du val soyeux à magny les
hameaux de liste se sont déclarés pour
les élections municipales le maire
sortant bertrand au lion est opposé à
lionel lindemann actuel conseiller
municipal d'opposition mélanie potier
magny les hameaux villes de 9000 491
habitants dans cette commune de
candidats se présentent chargé de
communication d'une fédération sportive
bertrand ou lyon s'engage d'abord comme
bénévole dans des associations
il intègre le conseil municipal de la
ville en 1995 désigné maire de magny les
hameaux en 2012 après la démission de
jacques lloze il est réélu en 2014 en
terme de solidarité de poursuivre
l'accompagnement pour la santé pour les
habitants
on a développé des des pôles médicaux et
paramédicaux sur la ville qui fonctionne
bien aujourd'hui qui répondent à un vrai
besoin
on souhaite continuer le travail a déjà
été engagée proposer une mutuelle pour
les habitants pour permettre une
meilleure couverture de protection santé
pour tous les habitants et accessible
ancien directeur de communication d'une
commune dans les hauts-de-seine lionel
lindeman est aujourd'hui entrepreneurs
présents sur la liste d'aurore berger il
intègre le conseil municipal de magny
les hameaux en décembre 2018
ils vivent
commissariats de l'agglomération qui va
se créer et donc nous on compte
augmenter le nombre de caméras de
vidéoprotection et comme il ya la fibre
qui est maintenant installée partout on
veut l'on veut les connecter aux
commissariats de l'agglomération parce
que pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas
enfin un mot concernant elancourt et le
ton qui se durcit entre les candidats
engagés dans ce scrutin
après des accusations portées par ses
opposants envers le maire sortant jean
michel fourgous ce dernier répond par un
tract publié ce matin notamment sur son
site de campagne il y est question
notamment est des frais de
représentation le maire sortant
précisant qu'ils sont votées en conseil
municipal et que la somme forfaitaire à
louer est utilisé par l'ensemble de
l'équipe municipale concernant son
salaire
le maire a publié son dernier bulletin
de paie sur son site également ils
annoncent avoir touché 1401 euros nets
en février dernier des enjeux liés à
l'évolution démographique mais aussi
forcément au réchauffement climatique et
à la transformation technologique la
ville de demain fera face à de nombreux
défis c'est la thématique retenue cette
année pour les 4e rencontres in cité
elles se dérouleront du 14 au 21 mars en
grande partie au théâtre national de
saint quentin en yvelines vous en êtes
le directeur lionel messi est un bon
soir bonsoir
pas d'annulation déjà ou de reports à
cause de l'épidémie de corona d'érudits
il est possible probable que l' on
rapatrie certaines des tables rondes qui
devait avoir lieu d'en chercher des
partenaires notamment une à l'estaca
quand le rapatrier mais pour l'instant à
ce stade comme on dit
on maintient l'intégralité des
rencontres alors cet événement il est né
en 2017 avec le souci d'éclairer chaque
saison une thématique liée aux enjeux de
société alors choses intéressantes à la
réflexion scientifique et a ajouté aussi
l'angle artistique des tables rondes
sont proposés tout comme des spectacles
et des spectacles pardon et des
projections
pourquoi il est intéressant de mêlée
justement les deux le scientifique et le
culturel angle culturel égal on pourrait
dire de façon caricaturale que l'artiste
à sa subjectivité à une approche
formelle esthétique et que le
scientifique à une objectivité
bon c'est pas aussi simple que ça dans
la dans la réalité non c'est tout
simplement que les deux que les deux
approches sont sont totalement
complémentaires et nous notre métier
c'est celle artistique c'est
d'accueillir de programmes et de
produire des spectacles en fait beaucoup
d'artistes s'empare de thématiques qui
nous concernent au quotidien et on a
envie de dans leur façon d'aborder les
thématiques
forcément il ya un angle qui est bien
précis qui est le sien à l'angle
formelle et esthétique et on a envie que
l'on puisse a présenté un tout petit peu
sur certains points avec une parole
scientifique qui est complémentaire une
parle de scientifiques ou une parole de
praticiens qui doit être complémentaire
du geste artistique alors en
l'occurrence là c'est la ville de demain
et ses défis c'est un thème qui inspire
beaucoup les artistes ce thème c'est un
thème qui inspire beaucoup les artistes
qui inspire beaucoup les cinéastes si
vous tapez cinéma et ville vous allez
avoir trop une liste de 3000 films qui
va et qui va sortir
et puis c'est une problématique qui est
tellement tellement actuelle je crois
que ce qui nous a au départ quand quand
on a décidé de mettre en place ces
rencontres une cité on se disait quels
sont les thèmes du quotidien qui peuvent
être creusée qui nous intéresse tous
quand on parle du temps voilà nos vies
s'inscrivent dans le temps lorsqu'on
parle de l'humain demain de la
convergence technologique
on a tous un smartphone lorsqu'on parle
de l'alimentation on est tous concernés
et lorsqu'on parle de la ville en est où
on sera bientôt 80 ou 85% de la
population mondiale à être concernée par
par cette question puisqu'on sera
citadins et que l'augmentation du nombre
de citadins est exponentielle depuis
depuis un siècle donc
voilà qu'est ce que qu'elle est quelles
sont les problématiques que rencontrent
les citadins que rencontre la ville
aujourd'hui avec ce lieu de la scène
nationale qui n'est pas anodin on est à
côté du plateau de saclay qui est aussi
un lieu de la recherche scientifique et
qui est en constante évolution on est
placé aussi dans cette ville nouvelle ce
qui a été longtemps saint quentin en
yvelines
juste pour traiter cette problématique
il ya donc tout un programme mise en
place on l'a dit des conférences fui
tableront notamment on va pas tout les
présenter mais que faut-il en retenir de
ce programme de table ronde alors juste
je reviens ce que vous disiez parce que
c'était un des moteurs du choix de cette
thématique effectivement saint quentin
ville nouvelle paul delouvrier
versailles ville nouvelle mais il ya
quelques siècles mais qui a influencé
tout l'urbanisme européen et le plateau
de saclay qui est une ville qui ne dit
pas son nom qui est une ville une ville
en devenir
lorsqu'on aborde cette question de la
ville il ya cinquante soixante questions
qui se posent là en l'occurrence on a
travaillé parce qu'à chaque fois on
n'est pas des spécialistes du thème nous
on part d'idées reçues de grandes idées
et tout notre travail c'est de sortir
des idées reçues en se faisant
accompagner par un spécialiste là en
l'occurrence il s'agit d'un journaliste
le rédac'chef d'une d'un magazine en
ligne qui s'appelle chronique des
architectures et au départ on avait une
soixantaine de thématiques l'idée c'est
de les regrouper dans les quartiers
certaines parce qu'on ne pourra pas tous
traités dans ce cas d'assez de doute que
je trouve assez intéressant c'est qu'on
parle d'un point de vue très didactique
puisque la première table ronde qui a
lieu le 17 mars restera des des
techniques de l'évolution des techniques
des technologies qui ont bouleversé et
l' architecture et urbanisme
il s'agit pas il s'agit pas uniquement
de technique ou de fait de fait
architecturaux par exemple l'arrivée de
la voiture ça bouleverse une
architecture ça bouleverse l'urbanisme
les voilà les matériaux l'évolution des
matériaux bouleverse absolument tout
donc on parle de cette table ronde
didactique avec des historiens de
l'architecturé pour aller à l'extrême
opposé ou de façon complémentaire sur la
ville fantasmé sur l'onglet culture
puisqu'on arrive déjà dans la dernière
minute de cet entretien j'invite
d'ailleurs à revoir l'émission c'est une
culture qui a traité aussi cette
thématique des rencontres une cité il
bien du spectacle des projections on
retrouve des blockbusters des du film
d'auteur et des films d'animation cca
sélective dans ce que le leitmotiv
l'idée principale de ces rencontres
c'est de dire aux spectateurs venaient
picorer voilà venez passer une journée
au théâtre de saint quentin ou à l'ugc
assister à un spectacle assister à une
table ronde aller voir un film mais en
tout cas essayer de vous nourrir de
différentes manières sur un sur sur un
thème qui est beaucoup plus globale
l'idée de ces rencontres c'est in cité
parce que ça concerne la vie du citoyen
mais c'est aussi incité le spectateur à
voile à faire acte de citoyenneté en
s'intéressant des as des choses qui nous
concernent au quotidien
un programme très riche je vous invite à
le consulter sur le site du théâtre
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
merci lionel masse et à merci à vous
directeur de ce théâtre national et ces
rencontres une cité je le rappelle c'est
du 14 au 21 mars à saint quentin en
yvelines
et puis de la musique métal pour
conclure cette édition le week end
dernier l'association met ta sauce
organisait la 9e édition de son festival
métal ce faire au programme de ce rendez
vous devenu incontournable beaucoup
d'ambiance et des beaucoup d'ambiance
comme ont pu le constater il obstine
berger et nicolas kirillovitch dans ce
sujet
c'est une recette désormais approuvés et
testés pour cette nouvelle édition du
festival métal sphère l'ambition reste
inchangée découvrir ou redécouvrir ce
qu'ils font la scène métal française et
locale pour le plus grand plaisir de ses
fans du genre moi c'est la première fois
ici je suis pas du tout du coin mais
franchement ça me plait énormément c'est
super sympa et puis bizarrement moi ça
m'apaise cette musique donc franchement
je me suis senti super bien j'aime
beaucoup
très très cool la salle de la tour pour
hier très bonnes salles et voilà
toujours une ambiance au top mais tu as
au génial deux jours de concerts sept
groupes à la fiche parmi eux
bukowski formé par une fratrie il y à 13
ans le groupe de rock métal vivait sa
première au festival métal ce fait c'est
la première fois qu'on vient ici j'avais
entendu parler souvent de cette salle et
puis l'accueil est super en plus on est
content parce qu'on joue avec nos
poteaux de lofofora pour la deuxième
année consécutive le festival s'est
déployée hors de ses murs historique
situé salle de la torah voisins le
bretonneux la salle la batterie à
guyancourt était elle aussi partenaire
de l'événement
la notion de territoire à l'est quand
même très importante
ce qu'on essaye vraiment d'être actif
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines
et justement le projet c'est pouvoir
développer ce fait seul métal plus
largement sur le territoire pour les
années à venir pourquoi pas avoir une
semaine métal sphères où un mois un peu
à métal ce faire avant la 10e édition de
métal se faire l'an prochain les fans de
métal de saint quentin en yvelines ont
d'abord rendez vous pour la double ce
faire en avril et le festival la tour
mais les watts en juin prochain
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]